I'm obsessed with all of beauty gurus I
watch all of their stuff all the time
they're fine still never learned
anything nothing is what I feel and I
try to but I still feel like I hide my
so scummy I wanted to come and shoot a
video of Carlin Aryan but more
specifically I wanted to see who are
your friends and do you know what their
faces look like probably not basically
there's a challenge that's been on
YouTube forever like who's that youtuber
that were you zoom in on one part of
someone's face and you've to try and
guess based on this completely pixelated
thing who that is so I specifically
picked you guys as close friends oh that
you often collaborate with to see if
that adds any ease to this game how far
zoomed in it cells dividing system I
thought it out looks like I'm a
psychopath in different areas this is
kind of a game but really it doesn't
really matter so you guys can try to
shout out your answers until we get to
the right one okay fine okay here we go
this is the first look like this where I
have to remember who this is yeah yeah
really dark oh my god Liza Gaby or
saying I feel like it's a girl oh my god
you know people's eye colors you're such
I think it flies our Gaby okay I feel
like it Gaby
that's your final answer I don't know it
can be based on the shape of the eye it
looks like they're from the region yeah
look at Liza you say Liza you say Gabi
the gay back answer is it was gonna be
what's for sure that was a girl I will
get ready okay wait there Mel it's Scott
how do you know oh yeah also to be Zane
we'll try to look at the teeth like are
those even teams a magic guy like if I
soft focus my eyeballs on it I feel like
it's sane that's what I'm gonna okay I'm
gonna say Scott but like maybe it's me
like I don't know difficult okay Scott
Zane crank enters scatter yes a good
friendship okay here's the next one
what the hell I know corinna know who
smiler that that was scary
yeah no offense
that's a lick it's someone's like scar
I'm sorry
I think it's Alex does he smile like so
I don't think so actually it is very
pale so like I feel who's pale besides I
don't know like I don't pay attention to
anyone but us Aaron but I don't get Alex
burns okay you're going Alex I don't
know see Corinna Corinna the correct
answer is literally there this is so
weird
it's very strange to see if the features
of your friends face like so uh people
just start like hanging back on their
walls decoration here is my favorite
youtuber
we're gonna really need to start taking
this seriously look get it together game
starts now
okay Randy goes the next one corral it
morphed what's happening no no that's
more of it slowly just zoomed in zoomed
in I feel like maybe you're right I
think Irina I think it's her but like
sonogram I want to say Karina for me
final answer okay Karina I agree I think
she's looking good and the correct
answer is it's okay it's okay
why do you have all the computer okay
here's the next one
Oh glasses is that also man who has
glasses Billy I feel like license
definitely when those glasses before
like the fake ones like Liza and Gabi
have both worn them yeah she's kind of
tan I can't tell if I literally don't
know what that I feel like it's a Liza
you're gonna say why sagres I gotta go
okay the correct answer is Gabi how did
you know about was a lip Ethan well I
thought that was me I don't know why
well their mouth is open so it could be
David fake laughing oh it's definitely
David fake laughing also Zayn opens his
mouth a lot in Instagram photos but Zayn
smiles he doesn't like me I feel like
this person isn't totally smiling yeah
my eyes are tongue out and David does
that in pictures with his tongue should
we say David I don't know this is hard
there pretty pale David has a fair
complexion David yeah
I thought that this looks like a vagina
pers that it was like to do Simon oh
okay here's the next layer
Zayn what is Zane he's it's when he's
wearing his jean jacket oh my god yeah
let's go I'm teasing okay and you are
exactly
[Laughter]
you guys are getting better it's the
game for grabs and they're getting okay
that one I don't like a movie horror
mister like it's a dog oh my god like
that pupil I don't know it does look
like very cartoonish okay I'm gonna save
link we have two more here we go
this is the second to last what Todd you
should go see a medical because they're
not injective yeah yeah I know I think
you're right I think it's Todd
Todd final answer I'm like who else
could it even be yeah we'll do Todd
financier is so skinny lip injection
then redone Jason touch them up honey
okay here's the last one
ready like these are the dark this one
that's really not and you can't really
figure out what this is once you find
out what it is you can kind of see it
but I like is it the eyes I feel like
it's Alex with that scary mask that he
broke into keeping one looks like a ball
sock I'm like it's a ball sack I wanted
to see if you guys need your friends
genitals and Oh mayor I have no idea I'm
gonna go with Todd you stupid because we
haven't done it yet it's the eyebrows
and the forehead it looks like a gig on
was just so shaded - that's terrifying
Todd your face looks like balls how do
you guys feel after playing the game I
feel like a bad friend
other than obsessed with Zane this game
I don't think have to feel like a bad
friend because means you don't stare
longingly at your friends face yes but
maybe you should we just do that now
people think it's so creepy
thank you for playing you guys I don't I
mean you got a couple correct yeah same
like immediately
oh sorry that I thought you were a dog
Liza oh my god yes are you such a blade
red make sure you guys go over to the
Harley and Aaron's channel because we
made a video are panicking video yeah
okay we made a video and I think it's
really fun I don't know what's real or
fake anymore about fighting
[Laughter]